there is a new report out about
coronavirus
in vaccinated people and unfortunately
as a combination
of some poorly written headlines as well
as people who maybe just are not
understanding the math of what's being
reported there are people reading about
this and saying oh
no the vaccines don't work um
i believe that a lot of these folks are
just misunderstanding
the math now the new report from the cdc
explains that
out of 77 million vaccinated people
in the united states it's believed that
there have been
5 800 infections 396 people
who required hospitalization and 74
people who died and then some of the
headlines
fomented what was the reaction from many
individuals
who thought oh no the vaccine isn't
100 effective which we knew no vaccine
is 100
effective another reaction was wow
even vaccinated you could end up
in the hospital if you get the virus and
of course we knew that
as well these are incredibly
powerful efficacious numbers of the 77
million vaccinated people
0.0000
percent died and this is pointing
to being one of the most effective
vaccination programs
once we are at full strength that
humanity has ever seen
vaccines are not 100 protection
we i don't know how much more that has
to be said the baseline would never be
this is only good if no one ever gets
sick it's an impossible goal
it's an unreasonable goal to see this
data
and to come away thinking the vaccine
doesn't work
is horrifying because this data is
really telling us
how effectively the vaccines do work and
then
to get this gets to a lot of black and
white
thinking that has been a problem during
the pandemic on masks remember
do the masks work or don't they either
they do or they don't they either work
perfectly or they don't work at all well
no it's a percentage if one person has a
mask you're reducing
uh in a physical sense with a physical
barrier the spread of the virus if two
people have a mask
well then you're reducing it even
further uh the vaccine
it's not 100 we understand that uh
if one person in an interaction is
vaccinated the possibility of spread
goes down because the vaccinated person
is 90
less likely to spread and 92 to 95
percent less likely to get it
so uh if they they're less likely to
give it to the unvaccinated person
they're less likely to get it from the
unvaccinated person if you have
two people interacting who are
vaccinated the possibility of the spread
is
even smaller and if someone were to get
it of the vaccinated people it would be
less serious and
if it were serious you would be less
likely to die that's
these are confidence intervals that's
how everything works
this really is some of the best news
that we could have hoped for and it's
important to know
that there's actually this these numbers
may improve over time
on the one hand it's true that of those
77 million
vaccinated people over time as more of
those individuals are out in the world
and are potentially exposed
some more of them are going to get the
virus that's true
but as more people get vaccinated the
interactions that
that cohort of 77 million has
is going to increasingly be with
vaccinated people and that's going to
reduce the contagion even further so
we're dealing with a lot of different
things right now we've got the paws on
the johnson and johnson vaccine
uh countries and and the us are still
figuring out to some degree supply and
distribution
we are waiting to see because cases have
have just been trickling up
although deaths have been continuing
down as we said yesterday or the day
before we're waiting to see when will we
really see the drop in cases
that israel saw israel say somewhere
between 50 and 55
vaccinated we're probably a month from
that
in the united states some states are
closer
sadly because of vaccine hesitancy some
states are further away
but the important takeaway is how
insanely effective these vaccines are
the cdc data confirms that and
and restates that and that should really
be the focus
and as we talked about uh earlier this
week and we'll we're going to look at
tomorrow
anti-vac sentiment is declining um
it's not as low as we would like the
latest monmouth poll
says 20 of americans don't want to get
the vaccine if they can avoid it which i
guess means if they
need to get it for their job some of
them would
one out of five that actually is enough
to get us to hurt immunity
but that's only from adults and adults
don't include kids so if we get to 80 of
the total population we will actually be
good and we'll look into this in more
detail tomorrow
the anti-vaxx sentiment being led by
republicans 43 of republicans
say they do not want the coronavirus
vaccine so
we'll dig into those numbers tomorrow
but the latest cdc data on covet and
vaccinated people
extremely extremely reassuring data that
is really the takeaway
when you see me sitting here at the
microphone oftentimes i'm wearing a
shirt by a company called
teddy stratford and i love these shirts
so much that i
asked teddy stratford to be a sponsor of
the show
and here's why i like their shirt so
much with other slim fit button-up
shirts
you often get this weird looking gap
between the buttons where it looks kind
of stretched out but teddy stratford
actually has a patented zipper
that's hidden underneath the buttons
which secures the shirt against your
chest so it doesn't look
stretched and most importantly it just
provides a nicer looking fit overall
and the entire shirt is specially
designed to really improve the way your
upper body looks when you're wearing it
it also has a special type of collar
that prevents it from drooping down
and spreading open which is another
really great thing about these shirts
all of these things really do a lot to
make a big difference when you're
looking at a shirt
and that's why i like to wear teddy
stratford shirts on the show
go check them out at davidpakman.com
teddy the link is down below and they'll
give you 15
off your first order if you use the
coupon code pacman at checkout